- Our next speaker, I'm really
interested to hear about
the STAR Program.
Dr. Whitney Ence is the
Director of Clinical Services
for the Service, Training,
Advocacy, and Research,
STAR, Center for ASD
and Neurodevelopmental
Disorders at UCSF.
(audience applauds)
- Great, I was just happy to
have Dr. Hendren keep talking
through my time, and then I
wouldn't have to go at all.
So, unfortunately, I do have to present.
So, I'm happy to follow
Bob because what I'm here
to talk about is the new program
at the Department of
Psychiatry, the STAR Center,
and a lot of what we do is sort
of the Level Four, I guess,
is what he was talking
about, so I'll be focusing
a little bit on our treatment services
as well as the other
aspects of our program.
Okay, I don't have any disclosures.
So the STAR Program, the four
tenets are service delivery,
our training, advocacy, and research.
This a new program in the
Department of Psychiatry,
and we really wanted to have a program
that clearly integrated
the clinical services
alongside with the research services,
and so all the families and patients
that come into our center,
we ask if they're interested
in participating in some
of our research projects
and data collection as well.
As you can see, we are a happy bunch,
a friendly, welcoming bunch
even on a cold, windy day
over in Parnassus.
So our mission is to lead the way
to better understand, treat,
promote the well-being
for people with autism spectrum disorder
and other neurodevelopmental disorders.
I just want to spend a moment on the
neurodevelopmental piece,
so if we can think back
to what Dr. Leventhal showed, that slide
with all the other different
types of disorders,
we also want to see those
individuals as well.
We want to capture autism and other
neurodevelopmental disorders.
We don't want to just be known for autism.
So in order to meet the
mission that we have at STAR,
we have committed ourselves
to working and providing
services to individuals
across the lifespan.
So we see individuals as
young, recently seven months,
to 55 years of age, has been
our oldest patient so far.
There's many programs that
are just focused on pediatrics
and we know that the
needs of these individuals
and families, they change and it's diverse
as families and children and adults
progress across their
development and as they mature.
There's just a lot of different needs.
We also want to be a clinical home.
So what we've found is
that many of the families,
it's getting very disparate.
They have school programs,
they have ABA services,
they have their
pediatrician, and there's no
one person to really quarterback
all of those different types of services,
and so we try to be that
home where they can come,
consult with us, we can provide services
and we can also offer
guidance and family support
to navigate all the different needs.
That gets really complex and complicated.
We also are interdisciplinary
in our approach.
So one major difference with our program
than the prior iteration
of the autism center
that was there before us, is that we are
really interdisciplinary,
and we work together
across a multitude of disciplines.
We've recruited people from psychology,
behavior analysis, social
work, speech pathology.
We have psychiatrists, and then we also
have our clinical research team.
So across our domains, we incorporate
these different types of disciplines,
not only in our research, but
also in our clinical work.
I'm gonna focus a little
bit for the next few minutes
on the different types of
services that we provide.
In particular, one of the very
large aspect of what we do
are provide comprehensive
diagnostic assessments,
and they're multi-day assessments
for our families, and they start and end
with meeting with our social worker.
So we really want ... So our social worker
is the first point of
contact for our families,
and then also our last point for contact.
We know that the assessment
is really just the first step
in the journey, for the
family coming to see us.
It's more that a lot has to happen
after the assessment is
done, it's not the end,
so that we provide feedback.
When I was listening to Dr. Leventhal,
I was really reflecting
on how he was saying,
how you look at the symptoms
and what you need to assess
and address.
And all of those components
have been clearly
incorporated into our assessment process
through our psychology
visits and when necessary,
we add speech consultation,
and also behavioral assessment
in the diagnostic
assessment, and we also have
our psychiatry appointment,
in order to really complete
that medical exam, and all of
our psychiatrists are focused
for working with
individuals on the spectrum.
These are the main domains
that we assess and look at.
We really want to individualize
our assessment process
based on the needs of the individual,
and what we hope to look
at are the different levels
of cognitive abilities,
adaptive living skills,
social communication, and
social-emotional development.
Our goal with the assessment process
is to help develop a
comprehensive treatment plan.
So telling the family
what they need to get,
how they can address the specific needs
of their own child or adult.
We really want it to be individualized,
and be a plan to help them move forward.
So just in terms of what we've
seen so far in our center,
we've had a range of
individuals that we've seen.
As I mentioned before, the
youngest that we've seen so far
for a consultation has been seven months,
but for assessment it's
been about 14 months,
and we've seen individuals up
until about 55 years of age,
and we have a few more older adults
on our waiting list right now.
We've also seen a range of
individuals with autism.
This is just the final primary diagnosis,
and this also incorporates some families
who had already had a
previous diagnosis of autism,
and they were coming in
just for a re-evaluation,
so we expect this number to
fluctuate and change over time.
And this doesn't take into
account the individuals
that may have comorbid diagnoses
that Dr. Leventhal was also indicating,
so individuals who may have autism,
but also anxiety or depression
or autism and intellectual disabilities,
so this is just capturing
the final diagnosis.
We are committed to serving our families
within the San Francisco county
and also the northern California counties,
so about 86% of who we have seen
has come from that demographic,
but we've also been a
place for an assessment
for individuals internationally.
So we've had families
come from China and Turkey
and also out of state,
so we've had families
as far as New Jersey and
North Carolina coming to get
intensive treatment and,
or assessment with us.
In terms of the treatment services,
so the level four that Dr.
Hendren was talking about,
we are really working to ...
All of the services really,
we think about how can we reduce
the challenging behavior or the rigidity,
or disruptive behavior
or aggressive behavior.
We also focus on building
social communication
and play skills in some of
our little kids that come in.
We target increasing peer interactions
across the lifespan and
improving adaptive skills.
I just want to spend a moment
on the adaptive skills.
This is something that we clearly focus
and target on quite a bit
in our assessment reports
and also our treatment planning.
There's been some really
nice longitudinal research
come out from University of North Carolina
from Dr. Klinger, showing
how important it is
to work on adaptive skills,
and how much that helps
with longterm outcomes,
and so we talk about
working on little adaptive skills, chores,
when someone's younger to being able to
pay for services, pay
for food, or do laundry,
or cook for themselves as they get older.
Those are the skills
that sometimes I found,
some programs have often left out
and they focus more on
social and play skills,
but the adaptive skills
really leads to high
longterm outcomes, so that's
something we talk about a lot.
Then we also, our
treatment services focus on
emotional and attentional
concerns as well.
So as I said, we're interdisciplinary,
so all of our services are
offered in different formats
with different service providers,
and some of them overlap
more so than others
across different time points.
So we have psychological
services, behavioral services,
speech, and medication management.
And across our treatment services,
the big overarching process
throughout all of them
is focus on evidence based interventions.
Then within that, we
really focus on the child
and the family first, and
as I said in the beginning,
we know that it's not just our child,
or the family in isolation.
There are different rings of providers
and different people in their life
that is impacting their ability
to function in the world,
or the skills that they're learning,
so we want to help coordinate those
different types of services as well.
So we really focus on
working with the family,
engaging in parent training,
and also consulting
and talking with other
providers, ABA providers,
school services, the place of work
that the individual may be at.
The way we provide the services
is a different modality.
We have some individual services.
We have a huge arm of family support,
so for families who just
have had a recent diagnosis,
or they are struggling to
figure out the different types
of connections that they can make,
or service systems, how to navigate that,
we have our social worker leading the way
with our family support services.
We provide consultation,
and a big component
of our service delivery
model is parent training.
So we focus on working with the parents
in order to teach them how
to implement the skills.
And this goes way back to the
early studies of Ivar Lovaas
at UCLA who found, if you
just work in the clinic
and don't train the parents,
the skills that the children learn
will decrease over time.
So we know that we have to
work with training the parents
or any caregiver, or any other individual
in that child's life, or adult's life
to really produce meaningful
and longterm outcomes.
So that is a big area of focus of ours.
We also want to try serve a wide number
of individuals and families,
so we've also offered
a number of different group services.
Our services focus on a wide range
of different types of treatment models.
Our behavioral and speech services
really take into account that naturalistic
developmental behavioral intervention
is a new turn that's used
for more naturalistic type
of applied behavior analysis programs.
Two that we use prominently in our clinic
are Pivotal Response
Treatment or training, PRT,
and also the Early Start Denver Model
that Dr. Hedren was speaking
about with Sally Rogers.
We also across our behavioral programs,
use positive behavior
support and a component
of optimistic parenting.
We incorporate, when
needed, Structured Teaching
or visual supports from TEACCH
and behavioral activation, and for
our individuals with
other comorbid conditions,
anxiety, depression, we provide
Cognitive Behavior Therapy
on an individual basis.
And we're also offering
a social skills group,
the PEERS model, developed
by Liz Laugeson at UCLA.
This is what we've conceptualized
as our Together!Series, and
it's not that you go in order.
You can enter in at any time
point for this Together!Series.
The first program is our First Steps,
First Steps Together, so this is a group
that we offer to parents who have
a recent diagnosis in their child.
Right now, we have it focused
on children two to six,
but we're hoping to
expand it because we know
that's not the only time parents
receive a diagnosis of autism.
The focus of the group is really to
increase the knowledge of the parents
in terms of autism services
and how to navigate
the community supports that are out there.
Two groups that we have
based on the principles
of Pivotal Response Treatment,
we have Motivate to Communicate Together
and then Motivational
Early Learning Together,
and these are parent groups.
There about 13 sessions
in total with nine groups,
and then each family gets
four individual sessions.
We include a didactic portion
of Pivotal Response Treatment
with video clips of
parents implementing PRT
and then the subsequent
weeks, families are sent home.
They have homework, essentially,
to practice with their
kid the skills every day,
and they have to video tape themselves.
And what they do the following week,
I guess it's not video taping anymore,
it's digital recording.
It's back in my graduate school days,
when we had the tapes and the ...
Everybody's recording
on their iPhone now, but
we ask them to bring back
their video recordings,
and we provide video feedback based
on the implementation of the skill,
so that's one component for them
to get direct feedback on
the positive and constructive
parts that they can do better next time.
We really find that the parents
are feeling more empowered
by engaging in the group,
and learning the skills,
and feeling like they can
produce change in their children.
The first group is really
focused on first words,
and the first group was
based on the research
that was done at Stanford, by Dr. Jun Gu
who was a colleague of
ours in Santa Barbara,
and what we have done is
expand that group into
our Motivational Early Learning.
So we know that the first
words isn't the first step,
but we want to teach social initiations.
We want to teach engagement.
We want to teach play.
We want to teach emotional regulation,
and so the second group
builds upon the first group.
The third group in our Together Series
is really focused on challenging behavior,
so again, it's a similar format.
This one is a bit longer.
It's half individual
and half group sessions.
So parents are learning
how to conduct their own
kind of, ABC or behavioral analysis,
understanding the function or reason why
their children are engaging
in challenging behavior
from rigidity to just not
liking when something changes,
or just getting really
frustrated and hitting.
So there's a wide range of
different types of behaviors
that are focused on in this group.
For our Social Skills Groups,
we try to serve the gamut
of age range, so we
have a preschool program
for children four to six years old,
and then we go all the way to young adults
from 18 to 35 years old.
We just started our young
adult group last night
and it was quite a joy
to see them all come,
and get really excited about participating
and learning new skills.
For all of these groups,
it's the social group
where the child or adult is
participating in the group,
but also again, that parent component,
where the parent or
caregiver is in a group
at the same time just working
and learning about the skills,
and then helping support those skills
throughout the 14 to 16 week group.
So it's a bit different
than some of the other
social skill groups in the community.
Our program, we are
trying to meet the needs
of the community, and so we also know
that the transition age, more
so than just social skills,
but other needs, so how do you get a job,
how do you transition from
high school to college.
What are the legal needs, conservatorship,
because to meet that need we are offering
a Transitioning Together group.
This group also has
the teen or young adult
and the parent group component.
We also found that we were seeing
a number of school age children,
about eight to twelve years
old and there was no service.
The families were asking
for a social group,
so we are meeting the need and providing
that group for them right now.
This is just a progression of the specific
group services that we have
offered since the beginning.
So you can see the
rollout from July of 2015
to where we are now, and
how they keep stacking up,
and we continue to want to grow
and meet the needs of our families.
So the T in STAR stands for training,
and this is a really big
component of our mission.
We offer interdisciplinary training
for psychiatry residents and fellows,
so they rotate through
our assessment clinic,
they also participate in our groups.
We are working to incorporate psychology
interns and fellows.
We've had neurology residents
rotate through our clinic
on multiple days to get exposed
to autism and other
neurodevelopmental disorders,
and pediatric residents and students.
We're hoping in the future,
to have practicum students
from other different programs as well.
We are lucky enough to
have some of our faculty
with very advanced training
in autism assessment,
and because of that we are
able to offer the ADOS.
So that's the big, that's the tool,
one of the tools that we use for autism,
and as Dr. Leventhal said,
you don't just use the ADOS,
you use it in conjunction
with everything else
and clinical experience,
but this is one of the tools that is used.
So we offer training in the ADOS
and we also provide training in the ADI-R,
which is the autism diagnostic interview,
so that's the parent
interview to gather symptoms
of early development and current levels,
and in the future, we
want to provide training
in Pivotal Response Treatment.
This is just to show what training
we've done since we've been open.
We have trained about 202 people
in the ADOS, and you can see
we've had researchers trained.
We've had a number of school
psychologists come in,
clinical psychologists, medical
doctors, speech pathologists
and social workers come to our trainings,
and we plan to increase, we're having
an ADI-R training in the next few months.
The A stands for advocacy,
and this is a part
of our program that we are
continually developing.
How it's conceptualized right now,
is we are providing
support for our families
and advocating for our
families within school IEPs
and coaching families how to read the IEPs
and to gather more understanding
within that domain,
and also how to advocate
for health insurance,
the mandates are confusing for families.
Some people have self-funded plans,
and they're not able
to access the services.
Other families are able to, so we try to
support our families in that domain.
This is our research, so
the R part of our program,
so this also conceptualizes everything
that we work intervention
wise with the research arm.
So there's different types of research.
You got to hear a little bit
about Dr. Hendren's research.
He's part of our group as well.
We have biological genetic research,
we look at symptom profiles.
There's epidemiological research.
We have lifespan outcomes
and also intervention,
so many of the programs that
we are offering right now,
we are researching and looking
at the social validities,
seeing how meaningful
the families find it,
how useful they find it as well,
so we want to continue to
look into our program,
see what's effective,
and how we can move forward and change.
This is just an illustration
of the different types
of labs that we have,
and everyone is doing ...
There's lots of different
projects and on our website too,
you can get directly in
contact with the individuals.
This is just, Dr. Bal will be presenting,
but I wanted to ...
She won't put it up there,
so I figured I would.
She's looking at exploring
the strengths and challenges
for adults with limited spoken language,
so there were flyers up on
the second floor I believe,
or first floor, however
the building is done.
So if you know of anyone
who may fit this profile,
we are happy to accept them
into the research program.
Okay. I saved time.
- [Woman] Thank you.
(audience clapping)